so today
taika is a kindergartener and it's his
first day of school
what are these what are these
um peanut butter box yeah
and then apple yeah then
cookies yeah cookies you got all those
snackables
and a little dessert oh yeah
you love those what are you gonna when
do you eat these
orange
and what is that
i'm gonna
no no the bag what is that called a
lunch box
yeah
and you always wanted one huh yeah
i don't know oh because i don't need a
green one because i like i like spider
missiles and then gives me green oh and
then a crazy bat like
like a
brown bat okay what else are you
bringing
that is a
yeah we don't like brown bags we don't
need a green one okay wait that's it
you're gonna get more snacks yeah oh
what are you getting that's enough food
that's enough i'm just looking for
something that was my favorite
because i like that
yeah i think that's enough i need to i'm
gonna go okay
yeah cause you're still gonna eat lunch
at school
okay what else are you bringing in your
backpack and also show me your backpack
this backpack that's your lunch pail
lunch bag
okay what goes in here
show me your backpack
that clothes
yeah the front dude i know what the
inside looks like the front
it's julian i can feel it
you're gonna bring your monkey cheeto
with you yeah but he's gonna be with me
okay now what else
yeah i'm not the only one that's it
that's it oh your hair is getting nuts
it's okay
that's my makeup bag oh sorry i dropped
everything it's okay it's okay put your
lunch pill in there are you gonna carry
it in your hand
you're gonna put in your backpack
yep
okay
and and i was having don't eat much okay
okay all right let's go see what papa
bear's doing what is he doing because
he's in the kitchen working away where
he belongs
yup a 20-22 man
hey don't say that you're in trouble at
school let's go see what papa's doing
may take a yummy apple cinnamon oatmeal
nice and hearty look at that nice first
thing hey where are you going we lost
him okay how does it feel knowing that
your son is going back to school
it's really cuny
because i see him getting older right
you know the more the older he gets like
the more of his personality comes i can
communicate and all that so that's like
i love that
but then also when i look at the older
pictures there's like two three four and
i'm like where's that little freaking
ball like he's getting elongated like
where's that little ball of little like
hairless monkey go
so now i do understand where like a lot
of moms feel where they're like but i'm
also very happy for this new chapter in
his life because i could see him like
learning exploring more things like
interacting more with the world and then
that part
i think uh as a dad
it
hits me here more you know because it's
closer to us scuba diving
cutie guy yeah
and
the cuny sentimental bittersweet part is
that tyka's not the baby anymore like
when he was going to school he was in
the youngest grade right so now the part
that makes me go
but the emoji is that he's a
kindergartner which means there's a
grade younger than you you know what
that means what there's some kids you
have to take care of now before everyone
took care of you but now you're a
kindergartner so you got to take care of
the younger younger kids yeah so if you
see someone that's younger than you like
in the e the skyler's not young because
he's six
yeah that's five no he said no
this guy's six
there you go that's yeah that's six
six we're about to be fine you gotta be
a good big brother to people okay okay
you look cute dude
thank you yeah thanks
look how creamy this is
grandpa's eating oatmeal
monkey cheetos eating oatmeal on the
inside strap for that grandma's eating
oatmeal too
look at that
the apples well i don't want people to
i don't know
fine
i'm gonna join them too
but since i'm diet sad boys
i have to measure it out
i like how you say fine like you've all
been begging you to eat it look at that
no i've been baking myself you know how
much i love cinnamon stuff
i love cinnamon stuffing
stuff though you got meat stuff you love
chocolate stuff you love
peanut butter i'm not you know i'm not a
big a berries person though i don't
really like strawberries and stuff
unless it's cause it's healthy except
unless it's peanut butter jelly sandwich
then together it's really
it seems like
[Music]
i think there's too many apples though
look how cuny this is
speaking of
diving to see sharks in this one we're
look
scuba
trying to see sharks
would you ever want to go scuba diving
and look at some sharks in the water
oh yeah there's trucks
but what if they're friendly sharks
they might be nice to you there might be
some nice ones look at these guys this
guy looks kind of nice the only thing
you want to do is just get a little
bunny fish on there
remember papa was snorkeling and he had
all this cool
videos of fish
[Music]
oh
okay so taika wants me to show you how
fast he can run ready
set go
whoa
oh my god
you you could have ran past me you those
are some good brakes
go past me pass me past me so you don't
have to use the brakes
i mean you can stop running though
[Applause]
good job
so i have already begun
the packing to our little temporary
apartment
and yep
it is raining right now
and it's 91 degrees
amazing
but this feels good we got our keys to
our new little apartment today
um and we got
date of when our house
will be completed we're gonna have our
keys in hand september 22nd some super
stoked because that took about
a little over a month out so
we had to lease this apartment for a
minimum three months all good
because if there is a delay
i don't know we just want to have a
really good cushion so we may be paying
rent for this place for two months
whatever we'll figure it out but it
feels good to load up the car
hey monkey
how was your first day of school
what'd you do i don't know
um did you have lunch
i had my cookie
but the teacher tried to put a butter
ball away oh
i know why
because some kids are trying some kids
are um
allergic
um that their body doesn't
it doesn't um accept peanut butter so
they get itchy
and they get like eczema or they can't
breathe they have allergies
yeah did you have fun i had my burger
and then
and then my apple and then my cookie
did you paint today
did you play outside
four times four times did you color
did you play music
did you read any books
do you want to go back tomorrow
what
yeah you do you had fun
welcome
to our little
airbnb slash
apartment for the next
month and a half or so
we just entered from the garage
right into the laundry room
right into
master bedroom
nice bathroom
what the hell is this this is the
weirdest shapes
what the what oh it's a bathroom in here
all right
interesting huh what's that
a closet
okay
and what's this
whoa a walk-in closet
crazy bones
that's a big closet
yeah just one no one say it
to now
we go to
tyga's room tyco's grandma room
whoa look at this
nice odd shape
closet
you can see
outside the laundry room that's where we
came from what's this
no we do now
okay nice sized bath yeah we're gonna
wash your eggs there's some seashells
oh cool your favorite what's this
store oh cleaning
okay
a little like
office area with actually there's
also
pillows
okay oh there's a desk
nice
we have a cozy little
living room nice
perfect sized table
nice little counter
some spices
nice little fridge let's go
balcony we got everything we need we get
some dawn julio
just the boxes of course
huh
oh
i came from there baby
well damn this is pretty cool super cozy
super cute
quite the change from our home to our
new home but i love it i love it it's so
cozy one second one second what i say
this is oh
shoot closet oh
he loves pressing doorbells
[Music]
got it
i am pretty damn excited to go where i'm
about to go so you know the house that
we got from my dad
it's about to be finished isn't that
crazy that's so fast and we've been so
busy focusing on moving out of our
current house
and into our new house
and all of that that i haven't even
really checked up on it
and i just randomly get an email that's
like hey
you're about to have your final
walkthrough to check up on everything in
like a week or two and i'm like oh [ __ ]
that's crazy
so because of that and i'm about to get
the keys soon i was like dude i better
get on the landscaping because when you
buy a new development
um a lot of times they don't have the
landscaping done at least in the
backyard some places they'll have the
front and backyard not done i believe in
the state of nevada you have to have had
the front yard done so i don't have to
worry about that but i want the house to
be livable
almost immediately so the two things you
have to do with any new house is get the
landscaping and then get the blinds done
so i'm gonna go to my dad's house right
now to one check up on it and then two
uh meet with the landscaper
to see like what kind of things we could
put together so i am super excited
because
i haven't seen the house in a long time
my dad hasn't seen the house in a long
time so i can't wait to record this vlog
and then i can show that to my dad too
here it is
my dad's
cuny neighborhood look at all these
brand new houses
they're so cuny looking
oh my dad's gonna have such a good life
here
it's all peaceful and comfortable
so the city that my dad lives in right
now well he lives with us but in l.a he
was living in el monte
and it's pretty hood
if you guys ever heard of a mexican gang
called el monte flores i believe
um
it's pretty hood there
lots of asian gangs too
and my dad doesn't even feel safe um not
even just from like the crime but he was
telling me like even when he goes out
walking because people drive nuts like
he's kind of scared to ever stop off the
sidewalk so we can't really go and
explore but in this neighborhood number
one is gated community
and two
it's like a very very like
chill
calm suburb so
it's gonna be so nice is exactly what my
pops needed
all right now he's gotta find which one
it is
all of these are under construction and
none of them have the addresses on it
so he's measuring everything out right
now
he's getting all the dimensions
this backyard is actually a lot bigger
than i thought
because before they put up these
boundary walls
you don't really know where the property
line like stops and ends
but walking in
this is what i see
i was like holy moly like it's actually
big enough to put a small pool
if we wanted to
but so far we're planning to put turf to
be a cool little area for like taika and
whatever family to come play
and watch watch how long it takes me to
get to the other side okay
it's pretty good size right
so i keep coming this way
and you have that whole area so
hopefully we'll put pavers there
just put some cement and then just put
some bigger trees along all these walls
and i think this backyard's actually
feel pretty cuny actually
because you walk out from like
right here
and then you'll see immediately
some plants
you can even put like a little picnic
table out here
and you have a play area patio
it's gonna be nice nice and cozy
all right we just finished the uh lamp
whoa
okay that coughed me up that caught me
off guard but we just finished our
landscaping appointment
and i imagine the house to still be like
way under construction
but as soon as i walked in i was like
holy
moly they have the tile done already
like this does not look like a
construction cycle anymore so i better
take my shoes off
my dirty ass feet
wow this is a good sized house
look at this living room
holy
and then you got the little
kitchen counter action of cabinets
go over here
it's the master
okay cool so they haven't done this yet
oh man i took my
[ __ ]
hopefully i don't step on the nail
oh
dang
in the
closet so i believe this
um house even has like him in her
closets
which is really cool
once they put the finishes in here you
realize how big it is
like i didn't realize how big this
house is actually it's
a really really good size crazy
and then you come over here
my man maybe me and my break are moving
here
you got one more
bedroom on this side
and then you got another one
over here
shared little bathroom
like that
little uh
three-bedroom house
pretty dang cuny
for my little pop-pop
decently high ceilings too look at that
it's pretty good
this is awesome he's gonna love it
not sure if you guys could see all the
way over there but there's an ikea over
there
so yeah my dad lives next to a bunch of
really cool amenities
purposely chose this area this area of
vegas is called the southwest and to me
that's like the san gabriel valley of
vegas like you have chinatown where you
have all of the really established mom
and pop like asian restaurants asian
stores and stuff so i kind of equate
that to the chinatown of la
but the new new all the dope concepts
like my favorite katsu place in all of
vegas is in the southwest so there's a
lot of like
emerging food markets and all that and
since my dad needs to get his asian
groceries i figured southwest would be a
great place because not only is
southwest
um like popping with a lot of asian
stuff it's also close to chinatown too
so my dad needs to get the newspaper and
all that stuff and it's close to
taika's jiu jitsu so we strategically
chose this area lots of really cool
amenities
and for most people i think that are
coming from a place like san gabriel
valley i feel like if you just pop
yourself into the southwest if you guys
are interested in moving to vegas it's
like plug and play it's so dope like
korean food japanese food for whatever
filipino you name it they have it here
so
that's it for today i'm gonna spend some
time with my cuny family and uh i'll see
you guys next time peace